if you are just starting out and you
want to learn the basics of Storytelling
of content creation short form content
is like the perfect one I think you
should be willing to adapt and find your
strengths find the areas in in your
videos that are working and kind of
embrace that don't have too high
expectations with less expectations that
allows you to have creativity and
flexibility and just try different
things right how are you using Ai and
what are some tips for creators that
want to go faster with AI
so what does it take to make a
sustainable living as a content creator
what are the keys of going viral right
now and how can you tap into AI to
create content faster and to be more
creative in your workflow I'm super
excited because today on the podcast we
have Jensen tongue who's got almost 400
000 subscribers on YouTube almost a
million on Tick Tock my man welcome to
the show thank you for having me Sean
super excited to talk to you dude you're
here from Canada first VidCon yes you're
speaking there's a big poster of you
with uh for your session how's it feel
it's super exciting it feels crazy
because only a couple years ago I was
you know dreaming about all this and
just like now seeing in real life it's
just whole another experience yeah I'm
excited to get into tactics about a
bunch of different stuff but tell us a
little bit about your story I looked up
your YouTube channel and saw that the
first video on your main channel was
uploaded nine years ago so today you're
working with Brands everything's
happening but like what's been the
journey attorney for you as a content
creator yeah for sure I think you know I
grew up with YouTube so growing up
um loved it watched it and made videos
for it and yeah going back I mean if you
want to go further back I got some
secret Channels with like videos that
you don't want to watch but uh but my
first video on my current channel is
nine years ago I started with short
films actually I love making skits and
like narrative stories and everything
like that and then over the years I kind
of dived into a whole bunch of other
topics like vlogging travel
um like working out videos I don't know
and then I think in the past few years
um the niche and topic that I've really
I guess hit a home run on has been
business personal finance
entrepreneurship and that's the niche
that I'm working on now and I'm really
fortunate to be kind of creating videos
in this field and sharing the things
that I love about it yeah do you know
how many YouTube channels you've
actually started
um me
um so you have like okay my secret
channel that you have my current Channel
Jensen tongue and then some other
channels I've made have been for I mean
we have the facts from Frankie Channel
which is one for the specific AI
challenge that I had I don't post on
anymore but
um that one I guess you include that
I love it and uh you also have multiple
businesses what kind of businesses do
you have yeah so I dabble into uh of
course entrepreneurship and I I'm always
thinking of new business ideas
um the other main one that I work on is
called storage Hotel so it is a
on-demand Storage Company
um so I guess the best way to summarize
is you know University students every
summer International students especially
they they leave right to go home but
they have all these items so uh that
they need to store for the summer so
what we do is we go directly to their
dorms we pick everything up we go move
it to our facility and store it and then
when they come back in the September
then we deliver it all to them so super
easy storage and so that's a local
business yeah it's local and it's uh I
guess seasonal and I run it with my
brother Edward and it's uh super
exciting it's like dabbles into real
estate and storage and everything like
that so it's fun and so how do you feel
about Focus right now in terms of how
you make a living as a Creator does that
a essential or is that part of
creativity and Entrepreneurship and
diversifying like what's your philosophy
with uh the different ways you're making
money as a Creator yeah like with
storytell I started it before I uh
started making a living with content
creation so I've just been continuing
with it I'm super lucky because it's a
seasonal business so it's still
manageable right I think around 2021 was
when I actually started to make a living
out of content creation
um so I think in terms of focus that's
something I think about all the time
it's something that's super hard
especially as someone like me that's
always so excited to start businesses
right I guess that's why I make videos
entrepreneurship I'm always like so
excited to Adventure into all these
different ideas but in terms of balance
that's something that's difficult but
for me I do know that I do have a really
big love in creativity in video
production and all that and uh so I'm
trying my best to kind of make sure that
whatever I focus on YouTube is like
number one I love that and you're
speaking here at VidCon your session is
how to use AI in the new era of video
creativity
one of your most viewed shorts I believe
was I used AI to rap like Kanye West
three million views
um such a cool video and you also not
only do you do the voice but it also you
have like a face oh yeah well so I I
made like a YouTube short version it
also made a full-length version but that
full-length version that in the
beginning I used deep fakes to to
implement the Kanye Facebook yeah it's
super cool and so how are you using Ai
and what are some tips for creators that
want to go faster with AI yeah I think
right now the ways I'm using AI outside
of just my AI specific videos I
definitely find myself using chat gbt a
lot to generate like completely uh new
scripts not necessarily I still write my
scripts but it's more about like
maybe I'm missing something like a
little like a pointer like maybe like a
paragraph and I just need something
quick then I use chai gbt to produce
something and then I build off of that
so I think chachibi is a really great
starting point in terms of you know
creating ideas or scripts I wouldn't
rely on 100 but that's all you need and
that's definitely better than starting
from scratch
um some other things I've I've actually
found uh you know like AI art generators
sometimes I need that like stock footage
like in one of my videos like I need I
need a picture of Kanye eating a
cheeseburger like you can't get that
online so I generated that through Ai
and I included that in the video and
it's perfect and there's just all these
other features like I'm really excited
about you know AI tools that are getting
to video editing right so you know
autopod is something that I I don't have
a podcast I'd love to have one of it but
I feel like I don't know if you guys are
using it but I think it's so cool it's
just like seeing it all cut up it's
crazy yeah we are and so that's a
Premiere Pro plug-in do you use Premiere
Pro yes I use premiere for and Adobe for
everything you use Adobe whole creative
Suites yeah and
um you edit all your own videos and and
shorts and long form yeah I edit all of
them um I feel like my film background I
guess really taught me to kind of deal
with all that so what are some lessons
you've learned from some of your top
viewed videos you did a 30-day body
transformation at a playground yes
really good thumbnail and uh two years
ago four million views what lessons did
you learn the video is eight minutes
long why did it blow up do you think
yeah I think with that video and
speaking of that video but also the
other videos like even my recent ones I
have one called how I made a YouTube
channel using only Ai and um and some
other ones too those videos they were
Challenge videos right and I think with
YouTube and just how the audience they
just love they love Challenge videos
they love seeing you know from point A
to point B and that's something that
carries a viewer all the way to the end
I think that kind of um storytelling
structure is really useful another thing
would be I guess you know within those
videos
um I always try to add as much variety
as possible so in that workout video for
example I work on a playground but it's
not just me working on the playground
and like I don't know showing tips like
there's like there's a part where I'm
playing soccer there's a part where uh
you know that I face a bear at the
playground like it's really all these
crazy things I try to implement that and
that keeps the audience with new
um things to see all the time did you
actually face a bear was that where I
live there's actual Bears okay so I was
in that video I was warned about a bear
some person actually came up to me was
like yo there's a bear in the area but
but then I just like in the video I'm
just like oh my God there's a bear got
it and then yeah that's amazing and so
when you also talk about a challenge
like this it took you 30 days of filming
yeah oh yeah 30 days and then you also
have the editing yeah so you actually
were capturing systematically the
transformation and footage each day were
you editing as you went yeah so I think
uh for that video yes I was because at
the at that time I didn't know the exact
uh kind of Direction I was going with
the video like I could focus on you know
my experience working on a playground
for fun but it all could also be from
like an educational standpoint like I
don't know which one right so I'm always
exploring different ideas and through
editing is it's like that's when you
kind of see which what is working or not
so that video I was editing throughout
it and then at the end I was able to you
kind of when you're editing you kind of
get to see the ending and then you're
like okay now I need to film certain
Clips to finish the story up and that's
and that's how I did it yeah I got you
and so this kind of brings up this
question that is a massive debate and
that is quantity versus quality on you
YouTube uh which one do you think it is
for creators because you're asking the
person that posts like once every two
months or something like that I think
for me you know I always hear about that
especially like
you know growing up and then you see
like I don't know garyvee for example is
like yo you gotta post every second and
everything right like 89 pieces of
content a day or whatever crazy and you
know I've always tried my best to post
as much as possible but I've it's really
something that you have to
ask yourself like what are your
strengths because of what I've realized
over the years is that I'm someone like
you could tell me to post 30 videos like
a month or whatever but like I just I
kind of have like a perfectionist
mentality in me and no matter what I do
like I can't really fight it so what
what can I do it's either like do you
fight it or do what do you use it as a
strength so instead of like posting 30
videos a month why don't I just make the
best videos
um best video possible and and yes you
do I do have to optimize it to get as
many views as possible to like make sure
it does perform but um if I can do that
then it'll still end up
um doing you know uh you know the
numbers that I want or the growth that I
want yeah it kind of sounds like a
self-awareness thing too because you're
self-aware of your own strengths and of
your style of content like maybe some if
your show is about doing real estate
market updates every day with the rates
changing it's an entirely different
thing than it is doing kind of these
creative of film meets YouTuber meets
your personality type of videos and so
you're definitely quality though if you
had to pick one yeah yeah quality yeah
it's it's quality for you
um what did you learn from uh this video
got almost two million views day in the
life of a 23 year old entrepreneur
realistic
yeah videos about me just like in a day
in life
um but I I know that in the personal
finance entrepreneurship field there's a
lot of you know there's definitely a lot
of cool people but there's a lot of
people that are just like I don't know
scummy like bad whatever right
um and I I'm you know I try not to be
one of those I know I'm not one of those
so I so in that video I want to portray
like a realistic one one that's not
where um there's like flashing flashy
like cars or whatever clothes or
whatever if you see the beginning of the
video I have like a Lambo but it's not
my last name
would you get a Lambo no I wouldn't I
wouldn't um so you know it's funny like
I I ride an electric scooter you know
yeah it's just like I just live I try to
live a humble lifestyle so yeah
um but that video it showed me that
people really appreciate authenticity
and uh people can tell and so I um yeah
I think that's something that any
Creator can definitely take um away from
YouTube versus Tick Tock for new
creators what do you think so yeah so
um I guess I'll tell you a little bit my
Tick Tock right so with my take talk I
have yeah almost a million followers
there but the content I make on there is
not it's not even related to my YouTube
though okay it's weird it's uh so it
actually started back in uh 2020 I I was
just entering Tick Tock at that time I
was like oh my God I don't know what
like this new short form uh type of
content I'm kind of scared but let's
just try it out and I made this video on
drift King so I don't know if you watch
Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift yeah but
I'm like I look like the villain okay so
I made this meme like funny comedy uh
skit for tick tock and it it blew up and
I kind of just rode the way for two
years and it got me into a million
almost a million um did you stop posting
so yes I did stop posting just because
of the the focus like I just want to
make sure I want to focus more on
YouTube If for new creators I definitely
think if you are just starting out and
you want to learn how the basics of
Storytelling of content creation short
form content is like the perfect one
because like the investment right and
like the how much you need to know to
get started it's like so much smaller
than a long video so I would suggest
that however
um you know for those who have the
Ambitions to create a like a bigger
story or or create bigger ideas they
definitely want to like you don't want
to like
keep yourself locked into that short
form structure because the long form one
gives you so much more space and
flexibility this video was brought to
you by stream yard stream yard is our
go-to platform for streaming to YouTube
and Facebook with an incredibly easy to
use interface for built-in branding
transitions text lower thirds and
seamlessly bringing on guests it really
is one of the best options when it comes
to live streaming and what's so cool is
they've implemented a brand new feature
called local recording take control of
your audio and video with local
recordings by separating out your audio
and video from your guests this feature
gives you the control over your content
for later use making it perfect for
podcasts and video creators just go to
streamwoodthink.com to get started now
would you
recommend a Creator starting if they're
making
relatively Universal vertical videos
that they also just Embrace YouTube
shorts and Tick Tock because why not and
uploading the same content in both
places oh it's like uh Universal as in
like I just mean universal like if they
know what their brand is if they're
talking about entrepreneurship or
self-development and you make a decent
vertical video would you just upload it
everywhere so yeah essentially you you
could actually be leaning in on YouTube
maybe YouTube's your final destination
but you could be posting these vertical
videos elsewhere and still making an
impact yeah 100 I think you created
something might as well use it to as
much as possible did you start a new
tick tock for just like your first and
last name with the I see you only have
just a because you go quality even in
shorts oh yeah oh my YouTube shorts yeah
they're YouTube shorts are you gonna
upload those other places
um yeah so sometimes I post it on
Instagram yeah only the ones that like
if it if it did well in YouTube shorts
I'll post on Instagram
um but I don't really make too many
shorts I wish I'm trying to
um but uh yeah like I back going back to
the question like yeah if if you can
post it everywhere yeah post it
everywhere I think why not what
ingredients did it take to uh bring you
to this point you've been doing this for
a lot of years you're breaking through
into success and a lot of people can get
discouraged in the journey how did you
continue to persevere and what do you
think the ingredients uh and what
stories in your life or lessons in your
life do you think uh gave you the
ingredients necessary to persevere to
make it to a full-time content creator
right right
um so I guess there's two aspects to
that right um so the first one is you
need you need like Obsession like I
think you need to do this for the right
reasons I I think as for me I
it's funny because I'm a entrepreneur
personal finance YouTuber but I still
see like I still labeling myself as
artists first and then entrepreneur then
business person because I love
filmmaking I love uh video production
and all that and so I always ask myself
like if YouTube didn't pay me uh and if
I didn't make money what would I be
doing I still be doing it in my free
time so I think that carried me forward
and kept pushing me to go towards it
even though I for years and years and
years like money I made like I remember
like getting three dollars of AD sets
every month I was like yes but I was
super happy so so you have that aspect
and I do think you really have to love
it like if you're doing it just for
money it's while like there's nothing
wrong about that like it's gonna be hard
to like stay in and be so dedicated
because there's gonna definitely if
you're starting out there's definitely
gonna be times where you're just not
gonna get what you want um now the
second option though is like you can't
you also have to be open to adapt and
find like success where it is presenting
you right so for me like I've went
through so many different niches like
travel and and um and like I'm yeah a
bunch of other stuff right and um but it
was personal finance and uh
entrepreneurship that I found success in
and be from that I uh really took
advantage of that I just kept building
my brand around that like revamping my
brand all around that now a lot of uh
other creators they sometimes they
they're a little bit like you know what
I want to make comedy sketches for
example and let's say they keep making
it but it's not working and maybe
they're just not like that they're just
not that good at it but they're kind of
like selfish in a sense we're like oh
you know what like I have to I can only
make it
um through that that's gonna be tough
because you're not willing to adapt I
think you should be willing to adapt and
find your strengths find the niches that
uh or or the areas in in your videos
that are working and kind of embrace
that don't like block it did you test
out those different niches on your main
Channel yeah everything was on my main
Channel and I remember all my friends
were like why is your your channel so
random and as only in the past few years
now it's like kind of normalized gotcha
so you tested out different things on
the main Channel we're willing to Pivot
and adapt to your strengths and what you
saw working and then that's kind of now
shaped your channel to what it is today
your promise is honest entrepreneurship
personal finance and self-improvement
yeah yeah and and another thing is I I
just just came up like I think a lot of
people sometimes they're always scared
of pivoting but if you're just starting
out and at that time when I was pivoting
to I didn't have too many subscribers
like No One's Gonna remember you as a
specific person just just do whatever
right totally even now like the amount
of subscribers like it's not like I'm
like Brad Pitt or something like some
huge celebrity that you're like Typecast
into one thing just do whatever you want
and um some will come some will go but
it doesn't matter who will go because
your future like the people that are
willing to meet you in the future that's
where those are the people you want you
went to business school yes I studied
marketing and real estate at UBC I'm
sure you probably watch YouTube and
maybe even follow some people who teach
business yeah I do yeah uh what do you
think is a better way to learn business
to learn to go to business school or to
watch YouTube and maybe find somebody
that you could
by their course or something and I don't
mean like a sketchy course but yeah yeah
yeah but somebody legit something like
kind of the online e-learning type of
world I think so there's definitely like
pros and cons to both
I think to answer your question I think
neither like okay I think you should if
you want to learn business you have to
do it okay like you can watch the videos
you can go to school and get the
inspiration from it but if you actually
want to learn and everything I've
learned is from doing it
um in terms of like either or though
definitely like with YouTube videos on
personal finance and Entrepreneurship
they're definitely the most updated ones
most like uh realistic ones right so I
think if you're learning how to start a
business right now like definitely I
think the YouTube and online platforms
definitely have the most up-to-date
content for you for University though I
I while like it didn't help me in
creating my Channel or creating a
business or anything like that it really
put me in a mindset of hey you know what
like I can actually do this and also
um a lot of social opportunities like
networking friends and and you don't you
can't do that while sitting on your
computer right yep yep
um and so don't go to college don't
watch YouTube Just Do It
you also should just do it and there's
great learning but yeah
I don't know it depends for everyone I
don't want to be one that says like
don't go to the university or anything
sure but uh I definitely think whether
you're in University or not whether
you're watching or not just do it just
do something yeah yeah and and the most
learning happens from being in the
trenches making mistakes failing and not
quitting yes what do you think is
actually the best
way to earn a sustainable living as
a content creator on YouTube or on
social media the way of actually earning
money sustainably from your perspective
with your experience right now
because a lot of people also
it's it can be unpredictable AdSense
could be up or down but if you're great
at generating content that gets views
maybe it's good enough and it gives you
enough margin there's other income
streams you can start a business outside
but if if somebody was thinking they
wanted to build a business especially
with your business Acumen and your
experience what what is the best way in
your opinion
to build a real business or sustainable
income as a content creator right it's
funny because I feel
I feel like inherently
the the profession of a content creator
is
is there such thing as a sustainability
to it I don't know I I don't I don't
feel like I think as a condo Creator as
a YouTuber there's always going to be
ups and downs like I don't think you're
gonna have like
uh like predictable months okay I think
it's gonna be I honestly think that's my
answer to that however you can make it
more sustainable by creating different
uh revenue streams diversifying Revenue
so yeah starting a business on the side
or you know like for me uh most of my um
income from YouTube is through brand
sponsorships but
um AdSense is definitely something that
you know contributes as well
um you know speaking opportunities like
at VidCon and things like that so I
think diversifying your income streams
is the way to make it more sustainable
but I think inherently yeah our
profession is kind of crazy
so you're helping people with personal
finance what are dumb Financial mistakes
you think that entrepreneurs and content
creators make
interesting um I think one specifically
for Content creators I think a lot of
them they over invest in the beginning
when they're creating content they buy
the coolest gear the lighting and
everything but like nowadays everyone
especially nowadays when I was starting
out I had to I was so broke I had to
borrow all my friends cameras I didn't
have a camera until for years right but
now we have our phones iPhone quality is
insane so I think so if you're like a
brand brand new beginner I think you
just start off with that and then you
learn from that and then you start
building up and don't but don't feel
like you
um need to have all the the content
um or you'll yeah it's going to be very
expensive yeah what would you say to
somebody that their entire retirement
plan is nfts
I think you should even though I'm also
into nfts I think you should diversify
it's always good to diversify everything
in life
um yeah what percent would you go in on
nft and crypto right now versus maybe
traditional Investments I think uh it
depends of course for everyone
personally I think okay I would say like
80 on the North and the proper normal
things yeah
um for the average person honestly with
crypto and nfts and all the risky stuff
five percent sure honestly but like if
you are a gambly
um or more high uh less risk adverse 20
but it really depends like I can't give
a specific well that's what I'm asking
just your per this is not Financial
advice but your personal my personal so
you're you're more bullish on nfts and
crypto I think is that because you also
believe in it you believe in the future
I think with uh and it's I think with
crypto I do believe it's like it's
definitely whether it's not whether it's
like crypto as in like Bitcoin or
ethereum itself or with just like the
technology around it I definitely think
it's gonna be implemented somehow in the
future we're already seeing it with
governments like governments and with
like real Banks like adopting it
um in terms of nfts
um yeah so I actually did a video on
like I created my own project Community
with that too what's it called uh crazy
as okay with nfts it's interest it's
more interesting because it's a little
bit newer than the typical like Bitcoin
like uh cryptocurrency so I think with
the use cases around that you know we're
still discovering things so it's going
to be there's gonna be a lot more ups
and downs with that
um I think the technology is going to
definitely be implemented in the future
uh how it's implemented right now I
don't know it might it might change is
there anybody you like to learn business
from on YouTube anybody that you follow
that you think has good advice uh I
think well you can you can't go without
like the the OG yeah I think it's great
um I think
for me I just watch a lot of people like
I there's no one specific but I feel
like it is important to kind of
open oh there's this guy oh
I think his name's like
clearer clear something tax clear value
taxes
so I love how like uh like concise clear
yes almost like low emotion zero hype
yes matter of fact good information
exactly it keeps you going on everything
so
how what is your criteria for your
filter for who you trust when it comes
to the world of because you mentioned a
little bit earlier there's a lot of
maybe more shady people or people that
are kind of scammy when it comes to
there's even memes about online
entrepreneurs Etc how do you filter who
to trust for you yourself personally for
sure and that's really important
um you have to yeah you gotta do some
research right because let's say the the
two people that we mentioned Graham
Stefan
um clear value tax like before they're
YouTubers what were they doing Graham
Stefan was doing uh real estate uh
clearly talks like owns maybe accounting
firm or something like that
um and so coming from those backgrounds
right they have real world experience
they're not just like hey here's some
random business ideas or ways to get
rich because that a lot of honestly a
lot of Finance YouTubers like they don't
have any of that they've never started
business ever in the past and now
they're giving a business advice that's
crazy to me yeah for me myself right
like I've had I have storage Hotel and I
think that that's something too I always
think about it's like this personal
dilemma of mine where it's like
I want to make sure I'm like as real as
possible so I also want to keep
exploring business ideas outside of
YouTube because I know there's while
while YouTube itself is a business there
are aspects of YouTube that you can't
find in other businesses and then then
you're not gonna be like relatable to
your audience when promoting another
business idea or something like that
so I'm always trying to explore uh new
opportunities at least try them out so
that I get to get those learnings and
then help my audience with those
findings yeah
as we land a plane uh someone comes to
you that you love dearly like a friend
of yours who's
comes to you and says I am serious about
starting YouTube
um but I'm a little bit nervous because
I feel like it's too late
um I feel like everyone else is already
doing what I want to do and it just
seems like there's a lot to learn what
advice do you have for me because I want
to start a YouTube channel right now and
I I'm willing to put in the work but
what tips or advice would you give me
for what it's going to take
um starting a channel from scratch right
now yeah I would ask them like what are
your intentions of starting it do you
want to you know create a like uh I
guess a career out of it or do you want
to create a career out of it I want to
make a difference in fact our community
think media podcast uh are very Purpose
Driven people so a lot of times they're
impact first but they they know they
need money for the mission so they're
looking for sustainability but they they
want to make a difference and they want
they just want it to work and they
um I guess or I could maybe make up a
niche from our community but you know or
maybe Craftsmen it could be DIY or
they're entrepreneurs that are trying to
move on
line and start maybe building a personal
brand around their expertise they've
already succeeded in sales succeeded in
real estate built a company or a small
business so it could be a couple of
things but it's an as you know you have
a background in film they're like man I
gotta learn video editing content
creation there's a lot to learn so
anyways maybe just a couple tips they're
like What's it gonna take what should my
mindset be going into this I'm starting
from scratch or I'm in the early stage
of starting a brand new YouTube channel
right now what would you say yeah I
would say the first thing I would say is
don't have too high expectations because
expectations is the killer it doesn't
matter like if you have big this is with
everything not even kind of creation
like if you have high expectations of
course you're going to be disappointed
in the beginning if you don't reach it
so go in with that but um at that same
time like with less expectations that
allows you to have creativity and
flexibility and just try different
things right
um you know if something's not working
try and something else and then don't
feel like you're uh don't feel like
you're
like the P there's a lot of advice
online right even my advice like you
don't need to listen to me right there's
a lot of advice
um but but don't feel like there's only
one way that one right way to do things
yeah because for me I especially me you
know the quantity versus quality aspect
I've always felt like oh my God am I
posting enough you know and then like
just like this like even the type of
topics I make and everything like that I
always felt like I wasn't doing it the
right way but I realized later on there
is no right way so
um for those new creators just go out
there create something new
um don't have high expectations but
allow yourself to really just you know
embrace the journey and see where it
takes because where it ends up because I
feel like you know eventually if you
keep pushing on you're gonna get
somewhere powerful Jensen if people want
to follow you connect with you where are
you at I am at Jensen tongue on YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock everywhere I I have
a pretty rare name so I thought you got
all the handles
um yeah that's pretty much it I
appreciate you so much and just want to
uh thank you for coming on the show
VidCon and uh I think media podcast
subscribe and share talk soon peace